produisons français faisons du made in
france une incantation formulées et bien
par à peu près tout le monde en ce
moment jean luc mélenchon marine le pen
bruno le maire arnaud montebourg xavier
bertrand ce jeudi c'est yannick jadot
qui défend des sons protectionnisme vert
depuis une usine textile dans l'aube a
aujourd'hui l'écologie s'échanger nos
moyens de production serré
industrialisés je fais campagne autour
d'un grand plan de réindustrialisation
écologique et sociale bref tout le monde
affirme sa volonté de redonner à la
france sa puissance industrielle de
jadis alors ce discours n'est pas
nouveau sauf que le coc vide est passée
par là la pénurie de masques au début de
l'année 2020 et plus récemment les
tensions autour des approvisionnements
en semi conducteurs et en diverses
matières premières montrent qu'une
france d industrialiser c'est une france
dépendante des importations notamment
chinoise et donc vulnérable aux
soubresauts du marché international bref
quand le commerce mondial s'enrhume
c'est le consommateur français qui tous
et ça tout le monde l'a bien compris
sauf qu'en matière de tissu industriel
l'hexagone accuse un retard faramineux
en témoignait la balance commerciale
française dans le rouge de plus de 65
milliards d'euros c'est le déficit le
plus élevé depuis 2012 d'ailleurs cela
fait près de deux décennies que la
france n'a pas connu d'excédent
commercial
notre pays est bon dernier dans le
classement des 27 états membres de l'ue
loin derrière la roumanie la grèce ou
l'espagne selon une étude du haut
commissariat au plan révélé par marianne
la france affiche un déficit commercial
de au moins 50 millions d'euros sur
environ 900 produits pour la plupart du
quotidien alors oui on trouve des
exemples de relocalisation thompson
computing fabrique désormais des
ordinateurs en seine et marne une
nouvelle usine de production de
paracétamol s'est implanté dans l'isère
et le coq sportif entrepris d'augmenter
sa capacité de production en france mais
on est encore très loin du compte il
s'agit surtout de retour de petites ou
très petites entreprises qui peinent à
compenser des années de délocalisations
massives opérées par de grands groupes
industrielle d'autant qu'il ne s'agit
pas simplement d'aidé à la création
d'entreprises mais aussi de s'assurer
qu'elles pourront survivre à la
concurrence internationale hélas le cas
des masques français est révélateur le
secteur a explosé dans l'hexagone face à
la demande liée au co vide entre 2020 et
2021 avant de se retrouver à l'agonie
face au retour du masque chinois deux à
cinq fois moins cher un exemple parmi
d'autres qui montrent que la
réindustrialisation d'un pays comme la
france dont on parle depuis si longtemps
n'est pas pour tout de suite malgré les
milliards d'euros d'investissements
censée changer la donne